- [Mark] Damian.
- Yes.
- [Mark] The last time we spoke was, what?
Maybe three, four months ago,
something like that?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And your story was incredible.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] You told the story.
I see a lot of comments
saying it's a bullshit story.
(chuckling)
A six-month-old baby
crawling out of a lake
to go back to the house it came from.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Is a little bit far-fetched,
but do you say it's still true?
- Yeah.
I mean, they told me
separately, mother and father,
like they were talking
about the weather, you know.
And they each told me
on different occasions
and they hadn't been together, for
you know, for many years, you know.
Last time they were together, I was,
I was probably like, maybe
two years old, if that.
And so they hadn't been together
for that long, you know and,
- [Mark] So you were at least,
at the very most, you were two years old.
Sometimes stories get into papers.
- Yeah, yeah.
- [Mark] Sometimes stories get
exaggerated or embellished.
I don't think I've told
a story about my youth
that wasn't exaggerated
in some form, right?
- Somewhat, I guess.
- It's just human nature.
- But from what they told me,
I was six months old,
had Cholic, coughing,
and I was a buzzkill.
And so they were trying to fix,
and were just having so many
problems with me coughing,
and them having to pay attention to me,
that they decided that, "we
ain't doing this no more.
We're driving down the road
and we're tossing this little
helter-skelter hellion,
whatever", you know.
- [Mark] For those that haven't seen
your first video, your dad was a biker.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Hell's Angel, right?
- Hell's Angels, yes sir.
- [Mark] And your mom was?
- She was a biker slut. (chuckling)
I mean...
- [Mark] So your mom actually,
another story you told was that
your mom murdered a guy
in a hardware store?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And that's true as well?
- I watched that,
I physically watched
that with my own eyes.
- [Mark] How old were you?
- I was like, five or six years old.
He cut us off,
and ran a red light.
My mom ran a red light chasing him,
because when he cut us off,
she slammed on the brakes,
and we were in an old Ford pickup truck,
no seat belts, and I busted my nose
against the dash, bleeding
and stuff, you know.
So that pissed her off.
And then, so she goes and runs
like, a couple red lights,
you know, chasing this dude down.
He pulls into a hardware store,
and she pulls in after him and she's like,
"Wait in the fucking truck", you know.
And I'm like, "Yeah, right", you know.
"I wanna see what's going on", you know,
I was a little kid, you
know, Curious George.
And so I got in, got out,
and went in after her
and just saw her just mangle
this guy, like literally,
until his body stopped moving,
and he stopped crying. (chuckling)
- [Mark] So you had a rough childhood,
it sounds like.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] With your parents.
- [Mark] What's going on today now?
It's been several months.
- Yeah, I mean, I...
- [Mark] You using fentanyl?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Still?
- And yeah,
and I went to detox though, recently.
And I was really proud
of myself, you know.
But then I was kicking suboxone
while I was in the rehab place, Arena B.
Beautiful place, you know, awesome place.
And for some reason though,
my psyche flipped out on me.
Like, I went wingnut on myself,
and just up and left the place.
You know, knowing damn
good and well that I had a,
a better future ahead of me in this place,
but for some reason, my
psyche was telling me,
"you're incarcerated. You're locked up.
You need to get out of here.
We can't do this locked
up thing", you know.
And so for some reason,
instead of walking out of
the front gate, which I could've done,
I packed up my stuff and
I jumped the fucking wall.
But the second that I got on
the other side of the wall,
I like, started crying and
kicking myself in the ass,
like wondering, what
was I doing? You know.
I really didn't understand,
you know. (chuckling)
- [Mark] What do you
think that's all about?
- I don't know.
I mean, I wanna say,
psychologically speaking,
it's just the primal side of me, you know,
not wanting to be incarcerated,
even though I wasn't incarcerated.
I was in a place that was nurturing me
and taking care of me and helping me.
- [Mark] The place was great.
- Yeah.
But for some reason, because
I couldn't walk outside
of the facility, 'cause I
like to walk a lot, you know.
Just see things, you know.
And because I couldn't do that,
I think that was the main issue with me.
I'm not really sure, though.
- [Mark] Do you think
it could've been just
your almost subconscious belief
of what you deserve in life?
- Could be, but,
- [Mark] And then getting clean
and getting your life together,
or the fear of that, was
too much to deal with?
- That could very well be it.
I never even thought about that one.
- [Mark] And you self-sabotage?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Because I've talked
to so many people now.
I've heard, whether I bring it up or not,
I hear these stories and it's like,
it seems to me like they're
self-sabotaging themselves.
Their own forward progress gets derailed.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] By themselves.
- And then I get thrown
back into the shit.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- You know and it's like, I
don't wanna be there, you know.
I believe I, with I mean,
with the good that I do
for other people and stuff,
and the good that I'd
like to do constantly,
I believe I deserve a better life.
- [Mark] You seem intelligent,
more intelligent than most,
- Thank you.
- [Mark] By a long shot,
and self-aware enough to say,
"I'm making mistakes and I
need to not make mistakes."
But you're still, here you are still.
- Yeah.
- Well, this is a really big
helping hand for me, though,
right now, because now,
I mean what I'm gonna do
with this is, first and foremost,
buy me some new clothes.
'Cause I've been wearing these clothes
for like, four months.
- [Mark] Really?
- And then, I'm going to
Cedars-Sinai for their detox.
- [Mark] Oh, you are?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] That's great.
So how do you get into that program?
Does it cost you anything?
- Medi-Cal pays for it.
- [Mark] And you've been
through rehab how many times?
- Once.
- [Mark] Just that one time?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] So this'll be the second time?
- [Mark] Good for you.
- I've always wanted to, and could just,
in the past, I always beat myself up
from my past, you know, like with the,
I talked to you about Thomas West, right?
- [Mark] Yes.
- Yeah,
about that particular stuff, you know?
- [Mark] That part, nobody doubts,
because I think there's
newspaper articles.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Showing that.
And it's like,
for some reason, I was
always beating myself up,
seeming to think that I
was at fault, you know.
- [Mark] To me, as an outsider
listening to your story,
it seems to me like,
you need to look at what those events
and that childhood with
your parents kinda,
what it communicated to you
about what you deserve in life.
Because you believe you deserve to live
on the street like a rat,
and that needs to change.
'Cause you can get clean from drugs,
and that's a great
thing, but you'll end up
falling back into something
just as destructive,
- Yeah.
- [Mark] if you still believe
that's what you deserve.
'Cause like, you're a great guy.
You seem to deserve better, but...
- And then, like you were saying though,
I believe that, but my subconscious,
for some reason, doesn't.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- 'Cause I mean, I get self-destructive.
And I'm not really understanding
that too much, you know.
But hopefully when I go to Cedars-Sinai
and everything, you know,
I'll try and get on, do something new,
like get with a psychologist
or psychiatrist, whatever,
and, you know, hopefully
try and remedy the,
the mental woes that are
holding me down, you know.
- [Mark] No, I mean,
being with a professional
would be a great move.
- Thank you.
And I really enjoy these talks.
You offer positive reassurance, you know.
And you help us out a lot.
I'd like the world to know.
- [Mark] Not if you read
half the YouTube comments.
- He helps us out a lot,
so I mean, you know,
you people should really lighten up on
that commenting thing, you know.
- [Mark] I don't really show it.
Like what I do after the camera's off,
I never show that stuff.
So everybody thinks I'm
just a exploitive bastard.
- Oh yeah, no, most
certainly not. (chuckling)
- [Mark] Well whatever,
I just let 'em think what they want.
I mean, a lot of people wanna hate.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] Just like I could say about you
and a lot of people
I've interviewed, like,
you just wanna hate yourself.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And that's not
gonna change by me saying,
"don't hate yourself."
And it's not gonna change
the commenters for me saying,
if they wanna hate what I'm doing,
they're gonna hate what
I'm doing, and that's cool.
- But if they get enough evidence though
so that it's proven otherwise,
- [Mark] I can, I can,
- they'll at least zip it, you know.
- [Mark] So many commenters are supportive
of what I'm doing that that,
I just hang onto those comments
'cause they're, there's
a lot of compassionate,
intelligent, aware people out there
that are hip to what I'm doing,
and a lot of people just love to hate.
That's social media, I think, so.
- That was my mother, she loved to hate.
- [Mark] I mean, like the
comments on your video,
the first one, are equally split between,
they think you're the greatest guy ever,
they wanna help you, they're like,
why is this guy not a brain surgeon
or doing something really great with your,
the pool thing, or something like that?
- 'Cause of a lack of
opportunities. (chuckling)
- [Mark] Well, I mean, there's
also the self-worth thing.
- Well yeah, that too.
- [Mark] And what you believe
you deserve, so just
'cause you're intelligent
doesn't mean you're not,
there's other obstacles
other than just intelligence, so.
- I could use some help, though.
And I mean, you're offering it to me,
so I mean, that's a start.
- [Mark] I think that rehab
is a great first step.
But talking to a therapist
and working on your,
what you believe about yourself.
And it's not your fault, it's just like,
things happened to you as a kid that,
- But we try and process it, you know.
And when the processing
gets totally confusing
and the semantics of it all,
you can never really surmise
like a proper understanding, you know,
especially with yourself.
'Cause I mean, I didn't
know what I was doing
and what was wrong and what was right
at the time because, I mean,
I grew up watching people
get beat to death, and all kinds
of horrible stuff, you know.
- [Mark] No, that's gotta
affect you as an adult.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] There's no way it can't.
- [Mark] Excellent, Damian.
Thank you so much for coming
back and talking to me,
and good luck with the
rehab, that sounds great.
- Thank you very much, I
appreciate all that you do for us.
- [Mark] I'm proud of you, man.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] Cool. Thank you.
- [Damian] That's
awesome, I appreciate you.
Hopefully this, this stay
in Cedars-Sinai, you know,
it'll get some good positiveness
in my life, you know.
- [Mark] But work on what you believe
about yourself, too.
- [Damian] Yeah.
- [Mark] 'Cause it's not your fault.
You didn't pick your parents.
You didn't pick that guy,
West, to do that shit to you.
It was out of your control at that age.
- [Damian] Thank you.
- [Mark] You have to keep
reminding yourself of that,
'cause it's very for
you to just decide that
you're worthless, because
of those kind of things
that happened to you.
And if you believe you're worthless,
this is the neighborhood for you.
- [Damian] You hit it right
on the head, though, you know.
That's, (chuckling) and I
don't understand, you know,
why I think I'm so worthless, you know.
I think probably because it's
the easiest road to take.
- [Mark] It's an easy one.
You don't have to try.
- [Damian] Yeah.
- [Mark] No, 'cause
even for people like me
that don't have these drug
addiction issues or whatever,
you still struggle to love yourself.
We still do, everybody does.
So, there's always a struggle.
- [Damian] I hope that
you love yourself, you know,
as much as I should.
- [Mark] (chuckling) Likewise.
- [Damian] Because you all
are doing a lot of good
for the people out here,
just to let you know.
- [Mark] Oh, that's great to hear.
- [Damian] A lot of people
talk positive about you.
- [Mark] Awesome. Thank you, man.
- [Damian] Yeah, thank you.